good afternoon i'm lieutenant ray
spencer and i'm the homicide lieutenant
with the las vegas metropolitan police
department
we thought it was very important to have
you here this afternoon so we could
address multiple questions but also
express our gratitude to the multiple
law enforcement agencies that have made
this arrest
possible specifically the
local office here of the fbi and also
the denver office of the fbi
along with the san jose police
department
i do want to give a timeline just to
kind of walk through some things
relating this investigation so on monday
may 24th the father of liam
returned home to his house in san jose
california
when the father arrived home he noticed
that
all of liam's belongings and all of
samantha's belongings
were gone there was a message that was
left for him
by samantha and i'm just going to quote
a little bit of that message but
she specifically tells him quote i'm
sorry i had to do it like this
she also goes on to say that i'm going
to try to get a house
for liam and i and that we can talk
about this in the future
there was nothing suspicious in that
message
that would lead the father to believe
that liam
or samantha was were involved in any
kind of foul play
or that there was any harm potentially
to come
over the next week the father basically
did not know what to do
it was on july or june 1st that the
father contacted the
san jose police department because he
wanted to document
the incident san jose police responded
to his house
and they spoke with him the patrol
officers
listened to this message i've also
listened to the message
and there was nothing suspicious from
that message
it indicated that samantha had basically
left him and took the child took liam
with
her and they were going somewhere else
he did not want to get samantha in
trouble and he chose
not to file a report
to document the parental abduction it
was
on the fourth when a friend of
samantha's
noticed the sketch that had been
circulating on local news networks
and she also knew that samantha was
missing
after observing that she then went to
the san jose police department
and explained to them that she felt that
liam could potentially be the person
in that sketch as soon as san jose
police
were presented with that information
they immediately
launched an investigation and were very
persistent
in getting a hold of me that is when
they spoke with me that evening
and that's when we begin coordinating
our investigations
it is the following morning that we flew
there retrieved the pillow
from liam's bedroom and brought that
back to our forensics lab
so we have the i talked yesterday about
the
information where we could put samantha
in laguna beach
we also could place her in victorville
since
the press conference yesterday we can
place her at a local hotel
here in las vegas on the 27th
she when she was at that hotel we
believe
from the information that we have right
now that liam was alive
from there on the 28th is when we found
liam's body at mountain springs
this morning at around 6 a.m members of
the fbi's apprehension team
in denver took her into custody
i will turn this press conference over
at this point to jeremy
with the fbi
all right good afternoon i stood up here
last week
announcing the reward the fbi was
offering for the identification
of our victim i expressed that this
child had the right to be
referenced by his given name
and he deserved law enforcement's
commitment to this investigation
while the outcome is heartbreaking
there's a sense of closure that liam
houstead will no longer be referred to
as a john doe
this morning arrest was made by fbi's
denver rocky mountain safe streets task
force
which is made possible due to the
coordinated effort between members of
the las vegas metropolitan police
department
the las vegas criminal apprehension team
and the fbi denver field office
well different cities fbi task forces
may have different names
in different cities but their purpose is
all the same
it's standard practice for the fbi to
assist our local law enforcement
partners if we have a tool
a tactic or a technique that will be of
any use
and this investigation we are fortunate
that we're able to assist in this case
we're very thankful for our strong
working relationships within the las
vegas
police department a las vegas
metropolitan police department and the
law enforcement officers within this
community
i do want to just extend my appreciation
to the media
for your cooperation and your assistance
in getting out as much information as
you possibly could in such a quick time
frame and also to thank their public for
their commitment and for their
assistance
in us getting to a resolution
so at this point i'll take some
questions if you do have them any
information on
the arrest was it a tip and was it 6 a.m
local time here or
it was around 6 o'clock local time give
or take a few minutes this morning
i'm not going to get into the
investigative tactics that were utilized
by
the apprehension team in denver
but it was solely on the work that the
fbi task force there did
that led to the arrest
obviously you guys have been working on
this case really hard for the past
two or so weeks how significant is
solving this case for you and your
detectives
well like i said you know our the entire
department specifically my detectives
myself
it's emotionally draining working a case
like this
being able to have closure
and identify liam was very important and
now
that we're able to make an arrest on
this case
is extremely gratifying in the fact
last we heard she was seeing in the 31st
at a hotel in denver a lot of times
past since then did you get a sense of
what she was doing in denver
was she still concentrated hotels any
idea why she
chose in denver we don't know why she
was in denver i know
like i said we had we had her in
colorado even before
the hotel room on the 31st
and we do know she was again at a hotel
this morning in denver
why denver we don't know we have
detectives that are
on the ground right now conducting
interviews with her and
again that's ongoing so some of that
information could come out
as a result of those yes did you believe
that she was alone during this
to the last week or so during the time
that liam was killed
we believe she was alone at that time
was she also a woman in denver when she
was found she was not alone in denver
when she was found however
the person that was taken that she was
with in denver we do not believe
has any involvement whatsoever in this
case
okay i'll come back with you ken was
rodriguez uh
arrested peacefully was there any
resistance or anything like that
she was taken into custody without
incident what happens uh
to the car is it considered part of
evidence and how what do you do
since it's in denver and you guys are
here so we are currently making
arrangements
the fbi sealed the vehicle this morning
when she was taken into custody we will
have that vehicle towed back to las
vegas
and processed at the lvmpd forensics lab
okay
the person she was found in denver is
male or female uh she was with a male
and
uh this morning that is correct so
one person a male in denver had she
stayed in some place other than a hotel
that we don't know at this point and
again we're in the process of
interviewing her right now
yes um trying to piece this together
she left she went to laguna she was
there for like a day and a half and then
came to las vegas
it seems
it appears and this is just our
detective speculating that she drove
down pacific coast highway
when we have her in laguna beach and
then shortly thereafter she's in the
victorville area we don't know why that
route was taken
vanessa when you're trying to identify
a body and in particular a child like
this and you have that
sketch and you're asking for information
how does that information get to
other police departments and how much do
you rely on them
if they do have a missing child and i
know in this case it wasn't a missing
report but
how much do you rely on the other
departments well that information we
coordinate through the national center
for missing and exploited children and
i also going back i we would also not be
here if it was not the
work that the national center did their
cooperation and their assistance
is paramount in this investigation so
when that sketch is
generated that sketch is sent out to
multiple agencies but again you're
looking at a sketch i mean
i'll tell you what i've learned over the
last 10 days is how
many missing children there are
nationally i was inundated
with reports of missing children from
all over the united states and when i
said we had hundreds of tips come in
we were going through all of those
because there are so many
missing children in the united states
and trying to
make an identification from the
photograph of the missing children
you know it's a very complicated and
time-consuming process
yes do we know the relationship between
liam's father
and rodriguez are they married are they
divorced do they have joint custody
what's going on i believe it's a common
law type marriage they've been together
for an extensive amount of time they're
both the parents of liam
will you tell us how liam died
right now we're not going to get into
the specifics on how he died we do
have an idea of how he died until the
coroner releases the
actual result of the autopsy which is
pending toxicology
we're not going to discuss that at this
point and just to follow up on your next
question
uh we the fbi does not disclose or
discuss
uh the results of reward uh the results
of the reward money so
is there any clear picture of why this
this may have happened
as far as again we should have a little
bit better idea
on motive once we get to the
investigation
continues like i said we're in denver
right now we're still following up on a
lot of those leads so
is it is it too early to ask you
about this special needs uh
relationship or the special needs of
liam
i don't i don't deserve refers to those
in an email to the san jose regardless
of what the father has discussed is
we don't discuss medical uh medical
history or information
uh publicly yes can you get a sense of
her mental state
when she was arrested is competency
gonna play a role here and what's the
timeline for getting her back to
las vegas so i'll address the second
part of your question not the first so
in the timeline is right now she will
have an option to waive extradition
if she waives extradition she would
probably be back in las vegas by the end
of the week
if she fights that then we'll obtain a
governor's warrant and that could be up
to 30 days
vanessa do you believe that leah may
have been the victim of
long-term abuse and do you know if any
child
welfare agency had ever been involved
with this family
there is nothing that indicates there
was any type of long-term abuse
whatsoever
nor any type of involvement with social
services prior to that
okay and now you're not releasing uh the
cause of death right now but is it fair
to say that he died in vegas
yes we are 100 percent confident
that he was killed here
in clark county uh specifically we
believe he was actually killed
in mountain springs yes uh
is there any indication between
rodriguez and liam's
father that there was any sort of
domestic strife between them that would
cause her to
maybe take the child or anything no
there again
you know and i kind of addressed that
there was nothing you know obviously
they've been together
you know i don't know their you know
personal relationship as far as that but
there was nothing
that indicates that there was no prior
involvement with the san jose police
department
so i'll take one more question yeah go
ahead
i know you mentioned toxicology was
there a weapon involved in the
um i'm i'm not going to answer that
question specifically
yeah i'll take one more you listen to
the
her message other here she intended on
finding a house and moving out did you
believe
that message do you reason to believe
that she had good intent
i don't know what her intent was but
i'll tell you from listening to the
message
you know there was nothing that
indicated
any type of suspicion or foul play and
that's
you know what the father expressed as
well the father was you know
didn't know what to do after the week
took place
that's when he contacted the police and
then he still again chose not to make a
report
for any type of child abduction they
documented it per his request
and that's what took place there right
now do you know where samantha stayed on
the night of the 26th wednesday night
it would have been the night they were
less seeing
laguna than victorville presumably
coming here
so again still early on i do know where
she stayed on the 27th so we're still
working those type of things and we
eventually have those were they in a
hotel or did they stay in the car
on the 27th on the 27th they were in a
hotel here locally so thank you guys